Before moving on, let's quickly recap
a few of the big ideas of this lesson.
These ideas all stemmed from the fact
that graph partitioning is indeed
complete.
That means you'll naturally want some
algorithms with good heuristics.
Some of the heuristics that we talked
about included multi level partitioning,
based on divide and conquer,
exploiting special structure,
like plainarity, and the no gain
is pain improvement techniques,
like what you saw in the KL algorithm.
The last method we talked about
was spectral partitioning.
That exploits the spooky relationship
between graphs, and matrices.
Now, you might be confused about at
least one more thing in this lesson.
Both KL, and spectral partitioning
are really expensive compared to
the original motivation for partitioning
which was a relatively cheap BFS.
So, why would you ever partition for
BFS?
To answer that question,
you will need to think about how all
of the ideas in the lesson connect.